hey guys Pete here mr. robot season 2
episode 10 was a big one this will be my
episode 10 recap and review and will
contain spoilers for everything that's
happened in the show up until this point
I know I know it's super late this week
but I had to take some work to pay the
bills I know this won't get a lot of
views because of the late release but I
love the show and this episode was
amazing so I couldn't skip it I get
mixed feedback in the comments some
people really like the scene by scene
breakdown but others just want the
overview so what I'm gonna do this time
is do the scene by scene and then paste
the time stamp link in the description
to where that end after that point I
will talk about where all the major
characters are and some theory and
spoiler stuff that's come up since the
show air there's a lot to talk about so
let's get right into it we start the
episode out with the return from Terry
Colby who is visiting Phillip price in
his office find out that price is
pulling in a favor to give China a leg
up in the Congo this relates to Minister
Jiang's ambitions and prices obviously
trying to secure funds from the Chinese
government in lieu of the bailout this
loan will get him a meeting with the
President of the US which he believes
will help to solve a corpse financial
situation post 5/9 possibly more
importantly we get an insight into
prices overall motivations in life you
tell us Colby that he has always asked
himself if he was the most powerful
person in a room and that the answer has
to be yes to date he says that the
answer is yes in every room with the
exception of one or maybe two he says
that alone motivates him and he seems to
say being godlike is really the only way
to be we got a scene with Joanna getting
dressed to go out
we figure out this is before she went to
post up outside Elliott's place and pick
up with their meeting she brings Elliot
to her apartment with mr. Southerland
and mr. robot in attendance there's a
quick second where mr. robot says I feel
like she can see me and then it appears
almost like she does she explains that
she knows Elliot is working with Tyrell
and that she wants him to lead her to
him she thinks he is alive and Elliot
thinks but doesn't say that he's dead so
when he's saying he doesn't think that
he can find him it's not because he
thinks that Tyrell is so good at hiding
they go back and forth with joanna
offering a story about why she is with
tyrell in the first place she talks
about how she sent him out to get a pair
of cheap earrings from a woman they saw
on their first date and how she
basically encouraged
to sleep with her his willingness to do
what was needed is what sealed the deal
in their budding relationship Elliot
seems unpersuaded by the story and is
definitely conflicted by the info he has
from mr. robot that day shot Tyrell when
she gives him the phone he tries to
peace out and leave but she doesn't like
take no for an answer
I suppose we find out Cisco was the one
knocking on his apartment door and was
unable to open it because he was helping
or carrying Benson aka the guy who was
in charge of the balls drop in DC
darling he tries to suggest that they
should let him die rather than take him
to the emergency room Cisco does an
effective job of showing Darlene that
she isn't thinking right after she says
that their focus should be on finding
truck Trenton and Mobley he points out
that she isn't a leader which leads to
discussion they had later in the end she
realizes she can't just let Vincent die
so I'm is called to Madame executioner's
place but is unclear why if she got
called there in the first place
agent-in-charge explains that the group
who did the bailout ball drop turned up
in Maryland and let agents on a chase
one got away but the other two told the
agent they were supposed to meet at the
house she mentions that Susan Jacobs
lives there and might not be on vacation
but might be missing instead eventually
the agent tells Dom the reason they
called her was because a neighbor saw
Cisco leaving the apartment with Vincent
they were able to work with the sketch
artist to work up a draw Dom is pissed
that if the suspect was there that night
that they burned the house and the agent
says that director Comey is taking a
more aggressive approach to everything
after the conference call got leaked
Eliot is riding in the back while
Sutherland is driving and we see that
there's trash piled up everywhere and
the people are standing in line for
their 50 dollar allowance from the ATM
he wonders if this was the future that
he was fighting for and if wars weren't
meant to go on forever rather than
ending he wonders if Ray was right mr.
robot is there and says that these
people are certifiable related to Joanna
and Sutherland he wants Elliot to go
home rather than helping them and Eliot
says she's she's grieving and wants to
believe that her husband's alive Elliot
tells Sutherland they need to go to the
micro center because the cops took his
all of his computer hardware we see Tom
bring the sketch of Cisco into her
boss's office she shows him that the
sketch matches a composite they got from
Ollie for the CD guy when he
and she points out that they are the
same guy her boss says they are going to
put a put out a bolo which she says will
force the dark army to kill him she
stresses that they have fresh evidence
on him and that he isn't tainted but if
they put out the sketch there's no way
the dark army will let him live
she says they lost Mobley and they can't
let it happen again
her boss shuts her down tells her that
the slow roll approached she has been
taking hasn't worked and that they are
going to the media with it he tells her
she needs to embrace the bureau's new
direction she's pissed so on her way out
he tells her that they have a guy on the
cab company and they might know where
Cisco went he tells her to hook up with
him as she walks out the door we see
Elliot at the micro Center and he points
out that eet Corp is offering a discount
for using their new cryptocurrency II
coin mr. robot tells him if he ever
needed a sign that their work wasn't
done this was it they're talking as
Elliot is grabbing everything he needs
and the phone Johanna gives him starts
ringing in his back pocket the answers
to hear the breathing on the other end
and mr. robot disappears immediately he
asked if we heard that too and then sort
of frantically looks around for mr.
robot Elliot says to us that it can't
really be Tyrell right and asked why mr.
robot is now hiding Darlene and Cisco
are at the emergency room and she shows
him the transcript from his dark army
contact with an white rose he asked what
Elliot has to do with it and she says
she was hoping that he would know she
says that he was right earlier that she
isn't special or leader and that it was
Elliot that was important all along we
get a scene where she's talking while it
cuts back and forth between them and
Elliot entering his apartment for the
first time keep in mind here that these
events are happening on the same night
as the last episode Elliot left
Darlene's to head home and that's when
he ran into Johanna outside of his place
Darlene was listening to the dark army
when she heard the knock on her door so
Cisco coming back with Vincent and
Elliot Elliot going to Joanna's is all
right after that and we're still in the
same night we see Elliot setting up to
try and find out where the calls on the
phone are coming from while Darlene
tells Cisco a really defining story
about when she was a kid when she was
five a woman picked her up at Coney
when she got separated from the rest of
her family she ends up abducting her but
what is interesting about the story is
that Darlene didn't resist or think it
was a bad thing
she liked the attention she got and was
actually upset when the police showed up
to arrest the woman the next day she
says that she still wonders what her
life would have been like if she would
have stayed there but says if that
happened then she wouldn't have Eliot
while she is talking watch Eliot set
everything up and use an exigent
circumstance form to impersonate a
police officer he explains to mr.
Sutherlin that he can bypass hacking the
phone company by using this form to get
the cell company to expose the block
number so he files it as a cop who has
received information that a suicidal
person called their girlfriend with the
block telephone number while he's
working we see that angela is sending
him messages on his phone
Sutherland says that half of him wants
it to be Tyrell and half of him doesn't
but he doesn't elaborate on why instead
he just starts talking about some of the
people that he worked with before he
started working for the Wallach as he is
talking Elliot starts to talk to us to
drown him out he asked why mr. robot is
m.i.a he wonders if we can help him
figure out what's going on he says the
last thing mr. robot wanted was to come
back department and we see a wide shot
of the entire place he asked if we can
look to see if we can figure out what
mr. robot was looking for now this is a
spoiler city so I will talk about it
later because Korra Donna gave up a clue
to what it was in an interview and then
it's pretty easy to confirm what mr.
robot is looking after they look around
the room we cut back to the hospital
where we see this Frank Cody character
on the TV he's talking about the next
step blackouts
he says the proverbial they are doing
this to take away your power and that he
isn't talking about the electricity
there's an obvious implication that this
is stage 2 and it's odd that it's
sandwiched in between these scenes have
to be honest that I didn't pay much
attention to the other times this guy
popped up but there is a lot of theory
out there that stage 2 is about
destroying infrastructure so keep that
in mind the nurse tells Darlene and
Cisco that Vincent's injuries aren't new
and that he is on a respirator
she says they need to do more tests and
they'll know more in about an hour
Darleen and cisco decide to go get
something to eat while they wait elliot
talks to the phone company about the
form that he faxed over and gets the
current location of the phone that made
the calls finds out it's within 40 feet
of a residence on the Upper East Side
mr. Sutherland says goddamnit when he
sees the address and then takes a
picture of it with his phone when Elliot
asks is him Sutherland just says trust
me he wouldn't be calling from that
house so he knows the address by site
but doesn't let us know for sure who
lives there the same time we see the FBI
kick in the door at Cisco's place Tom
grabs his badge from the library and we
find out his name is Francis Shaw
obviously no one was home so nothing
else happens there back at the hospital
the nurse who helped Darlene and Cisco
sees his sketch on the TV she appears to
realize the Tim right away Darlene and
Cisco are sitting down to eat at a
restaurant not far from the hospital and
Elliot gets another urgent message from
Angela Darlene is talking about leaving
because she's worried that the dark army
took out Trenton and Mobley and will do
the same to them we see Dom arrived at
the hospital with other FBI agents to
respond to the nurses call since the
news is on Tom finds it weird that they
stayed in the emergency room and her
boss tells her that they must have saw
it and so they won't be coming back
Elliot meets Angela on the subway and
she asked him why he started fsociety he
looks around for a while before saying
he didn't want to involve her she then
tells him about Dom coming to her
apartment earlier that night from here
all the scenes kind of run concurrently
so Darlene and Cisco talk about one you
know waiting to make a decision and Dom
gets her aha moment back at the hospital
she asked the nurse about the TV
realizes they didn't see the bolo and
takes off to look for them
Elliot tells Angela he can fix this but
she says she's going to meet her lawyer
so she can turn herself in
she says they will always lose to them
and that she is going to tell them that
she planted this femtocell
she says she will just own up for the
part she played but tells Elliot that
sooner or later they were gonna catch up
with him as well Darlene and Cisco have
a touching moment while they're eating
where she shows that she has real
affection for him for one of the first
time that I can think of Elliot thinks
how can he protect the people he cares
about if every step he takes puts them
in danger feels remorse for hiding out
in a cage while they took all the risk
we see Tom looking around
hood and then Angela house Elliot about
the time she found him in the museum she
says he was yelling at the staff because
they couldn't see who he thought he was
seen she asked if it was her father than
two and he takes a while where it looks
like he cycles through a few different
reactions before saying he didn't
remember that at all
she says he can't work with mr. robot
and asks him not to trick himself into
thinking he can do that after that he
just stares until they start to pull up
in the station and she tells him he
should probably get off he stands up
walks over to her and then gives her a
real hug he thinks to himself that he
doesn't want to leave her and then does
something totally unheard is it's a real
kiss that lingers until the train stops
and he pulls away after he leaves she
looks devastated and we see two people
approach her there is more to this
couple than you can glean just from this
scene so I will get into that later Dom
shows up at the restaurant who finds
Darlene and Cisco she calls in all units
then goes inside to confront them at the
same time we see a motorcycle pull up
with two riders and one on the back gets
off with a gun and walks towards the
restaurant we watched his approach
that's timed perfectly with the
crosswalk sign and he opens up firing a
lot of bullets in their direction Dom
pops back up fires her gun and hits the
shooter we hear sirens as police cars
arrive and the shooter realizing that
he's gonna get caught pulls out a
handgun to kill himself Dom runs out and
we see she's covered with blood splatter
we see her looking around notice the
sign in the window now says lies instead
of Lopez and the episode and now there's
a lot that happened a lot of stuff that
got figured out in the time since the
episode aired some of what I'm going to
get into will contain spoilers beyond
what you saw on the first watch
including who got shot and what mr.
robot was looking for we got
confirmation of that in the trailer for
episode 11 so if you don't want to find
those things out now is a good time to
stop watching overall we are headed
full-speed into the two-part season
finale they were initially going to show
that those two and there's like a
two-hour episode but now they've decided
to air it over the next two weeks are
things are closing out of society and
Elliot is stuck between a rock and a
hard place for a review let's look at
the different characters and what we
know we get the scene with pricing Colby
that gives us a look into
his thought process who are we supposed
to believe that the one or two people
that pricin might not be as powerful as
Minister Zhang is the obvious person who
comes to mind and if price knows about
white rose as an alternate personality
he might fit the bill for both President
of the United States is often referred
to as the most powerful person in the
world but prices mention of politicians
only being puppets might be an
indication that he doesn't agree course
the idea of one or maybe two feds Eliot
and mr. robot as well this price know
that much about Eliot though or would
this fit better with the idea that he's
referring to the hacker or hackers that
put him in the spot he's in right now
the Speaker of the House did insist that
he resigned in the beginning of the
season so the hack itself does threaten
his power it you know it's really not
that clear if if he had someone specific
in mind or not but I think is
interesting here is that it is his
general philosophy holds him in a state
of constantly needing to consolidate
more power he uses God as the you know
in the creation of mankind as the
benchmark which by definition no human
can live up to this would indicate that
he will never arrest or be satisfied so
I'm not sure if that is what we're
supposed to take away or if we're
supposed to know that he has someone in
mind that is more powerful than himself
either way it is a great insight into
the frame of mine which will surely play
a part later it also makes me think
about earlier when he said that he would
rather see Jiang lose rather than win
himself and I suppose we could replace
thing with any other person's name that
he would view as a rival we also see
Joanna is serious about getting
Elliott's help and Sutherland make sure
he falls through he finds where the
phone is but we don't necessarily know
who made calls the best guess on the
location we see is that he is near some
but he's near where we know Scott
Knowles lives or where we could guess
that price might live there are theories
that saying Knowles is actually holding
him at his place
but other than the address is just
speculation other fans think Knowles is
the one sending the gifts and making the
calls but Elliot answering the phone and
hearing the same breathing makes this a
little less likely really Elliot's
answering the phone doesn't explain much
so I think we'll have to wait and see
why Sutherland said he wouldn't be at
that address during that scene Elliot
asked us to look around the apartment to
help
and try to figure out what mr. robot
wanted to come back to the apartment for
Cortana who does the technical stuff for
the show answered a question about this
where he capitalized what looked like
random letters when you took all the
capitalized letters and put them
together they spelled out bottom right
and the bottom right of the shot there
is a pile of mail and in the trailer for
the next episode we see mr. robot
picking up the mail by himself this
could be from the dark army many fans
pointed out that Leon mentioned he was
going to get something in the mail but
at the same time he showed a letter
saying he was getting out of jail to his
therapist when she visited either way
mr. robot is interested in something
that came in the mail while Elliott was
away from the apartment and in the clip
it looks like he finds it when Elliott
isn't around mr. robot leaving obviously
has something to do with Tyrell and it
seems to be that he lied about him being
dead and the 90 scene where mr. robot is
protecting Elliott from the beatdown
he's getting from Lone Star and the
other guards I pointed out that I
thought it was interesting that we saw a
Gideon dye again since that is what
happened to him in real life Tyrell was
locked in the trunk and mr. robot beat
him with the tire iron to get him to be
quiet but we definitely aren't sure
whether he killed him or not this leads
me to believe that Tyrell is alive more
than the actual phone call since we
don't really know if that happened again
either way there's probably a Tyrell
reveal that doesn't involve him being
dead coming up soon on the train the
people who approach Darlene aren't a
complete mystery unread at a few posters
notice that the actors who played them
were credited in several episodes this
season so short story is that these two
have been following in juror Angela
around for a while and if you go back
you can actually pick them out of the
background in certain scenes long story
is that we don't know for sure who they
are working for but in the trailer for
the next episode we see that they take
her to in a van to a house that looks
like a safe house we see all the
pictures on the wall have the faces
blocked out which isn't a great clue as
to who they are a lot of theories have
them as Dom's people basically people
she is using because she doesn't trust
the bureau this could be the case but
the weird pictures make you wonder if
it's consistent with people who are
working with an FBI agent if they aren't
working for Dom then they could be
working for anyone with interest and
Angela and F society you could literally
make a case for it being le
that sent them or Tyrell or price and so
on there are problems with all these
ideas though and there are problems with
thinking that they might be working for
whiterose since the dark army doesn't
have a problem with killing people
wherever she's going we might find out
that Mobley and Trenton are being held
there too which would be a good thing
but your guess is as good as mine as
like who they are or who they're working
for or where they're taking them the
last scene was the most devastating
especially since we saw Darlene sorta
come back to earth and we saw her and
Cisco really appreciate each other
before all was said and done the shot is
too far away to tell what happened in
real time but both the video and sound
have been cleaned up so that we know
what happened Dom comes in and basically
called Cisco by his real name and tells
them they are under arrest
they say they aren't going to go with
her and then the guy starts shooting
Cisco clearly gets shot in the head and
it looks like a like a ketchup bottle
gets shot in front of Darlene before she
ducks under the table so rest in peace
Cisco but it looks like Darlene is okay
although she'll definitely be an FBI
custody after everything calms down
since the timeline was so tight we don't
get any news about the Nuclear
Regulatory Commission visitor or any
other information about Washington the
township not sure how this was gonna
figure into the rest of the season but
obviously the plan is really important
for White Rose and dark army if not
China itself there have been a ton of
theories about this from it being about
making salt bombs like the doomsday
device in dr. Strangelove or that the
Congo stuff is related to electronics
production and that's important for
crypto currency like a coin but none of
the theories are definitive they are
interesting but the evidence isn't
completed enough yet to go beyond
speculation the mr. robot wiki says the
washington town plant is a factory like
a chemical plant but that is written by
fans and has no references listed as to
where they actually found that I hope we
get more info before the end of the
season but realistically that could be a
background plot point that goes on
through the entire series the kiss
between Angela and Elliot is interesting
too I know there are theories that they
used to have a relationship but I never
really bought into them and to me it
looked like something that they had both
him waiting for Portia Doubleday the
actor that plays Angela said on hacking
robot that she thought that Angela
in love with Eliot but that she knows
that never will be or sometime hits a
paraphrase but was something like that
so I'm not exactly sure if that clears
anything up but it the kiss was
something I didn't see coming so that is
where we're at and I know I am as
excited as hell for the last two
episodes let me know what you guys think
about all this stuff in the comments
again I apologize for taking so long on
this one but sometimes it can't be
helped hopefully by season 3 my channel
will be doing well enough that I'll be
able to give it more time please like
the video if you liked it and please
subscribe to support the channel let me
know if you like the times the hand
plank thing and if you want me to do
that in the last two videos for mr.
robot season 2 thanks for watching and
I'll talk to you soon